a California clothing company faces a
billion-dollar lawsuit from clients who
claim it is acting like a pyramid scheme
lularoe sells clothing like leggings and
dresses to independent fashion retailers
well they resell the items to customers
through online and in home sales some of
the plaintiffs say their association
with lularoe has brought them to
financial ruin Anna Werner is in Los
Angeles with the allegations and the
company's response and a good morning
good morning lularoe says it has more
than 80,000 independent fashion
retailers who have sold more than two
billion dollars in lularoe apparel so
far this year but now some of those
retailers are suing they claim they were
misled into investing thousands of
dollars into lularoe merchandise in
hopes of making huge profits we spoke
with one of the proposed lawsuits
class-action members who says that
lularoe wasn't what she thought it would
be I worked day and night it was far
from being part-time it was definitely
more than full-time work this one is
called in Amelia Gabrielle Miranda is a
former lularoe retailer she said she
joined the company this past spring to
spend more time with her family but
ended up investing and losing more than
nine thousand dollars in just a few
months the lawsuit seeks a billion
dollars for a proposed class of
plaintiffs who it says were unknowingly
recruited into Lulu Roe's pyramid scheme
through manipulation and misinformation
the lawsuit said that none of Lulu Rose
bonus payments to their consultants
depended upon an actual sale to a
consumer some of you guys want to know
how much inventory I got Aranda said she
had difficulty selling clothes look at
all of this but her team leader
encouraged her to buy more inventory
they're getting more money off of what
I'm investing but I'm not making
anything off of it I think my downfall
was reinvesting the money that I made
off of it the lawsuit alleges that some
consultants were told to borrow money
take out credit cards some even asked to
sell their breast milk in order to
purchase more inventory in a statement
lularoe said they have not been served
with the complaint but believe the
allegations are baseless factually
inaccurate and misinformed they say
their bonus plan only includes
incentives that were
retail sales to consumers lularoe says
it will vigorously defend against the
allegation and is confident it will
prevail consumers really don't
understand the way this works
Russell Winer is a marketing professor
at New York University's Stern School of
Business
he believes the company is not a pyramid
scheme if there are products that are
actually being sold to consumers then
it's not a pyramid scheme lularoe has
faced complaints about other issues but
said that the vast majority of their
retailers are successful and are happy
with their experience the company said
that sales have put hundreds of millions
of dollars into the pockets of those
independent fashion retailers now coming
up tomorrow on CBS this morning we will
have exclusively the cofounders of
lularoe they're going to talk with us
about their business how it got started
and also how they respond to some of
these issues that have come up again
that'll be a story you'll see only an
interview only on CBS this morning Gail
that's good there's always two sides to
every story so it'll be interesting to
hear what they have to say but meantime
anybody asks you to sell your breast
milk I think I have some questions I
think twice about that one
yes thanks find out their side tomorrow
always find the most interesting detail
in a story Gail well that sort of jumped
at me